- Hey, y'all!
I'm Mason Ramsey and I'm here at Buzzfeed
to answer some fan questions. (yodels)
(country music)
I don't know, I just did it. (yodels)
No one told me this, that I
was gonna be at Coachella.
And so I was like, "Where's Coachella at?"
And I didn't really know, so.
It's a big thing.
I'm the first youngest
person in country music
to sing at Coachella.
I just woke up one day.
Got the call from Ellen, she wanted me
and I went there and that's how I got
my booster seat, kind of like.
Alrighty, let's mix and match here.
I'd have to go with
Blake Shelton on that one
'cause he's fun.
Okie dok.
Well, I got a great one.
If there was a zombie apocalypse,
I would use my yodeling to kill
every single one of 'em. (yodels)
It'd be like wind blowing trees.
Hmm, that's a good one.
DJ Suede is my best bro, so.
He helped me out a lot, so.
I'm gonna say I feel good
and thank you, DJ Suede.
So one day, I was playing Minecraft
and there was this person on Minecraft.
And my cousin was playing online.
My cousin asked, "Are you
a big fan of Mason Ramsey?"
And she's like, "No, I think I'll pass."
Was like, "What?"
Haters are haters and people
who like you, they help.
(heavenly music plays)
My EP has very new songs.
My single released Famous, Yo Da Lady Who.
If you listen to that,
that song's on my EP too.
That one is a killer.
That's a bop, bop.
Like, it's a line dancing song.
I just sing.
I'm a singer who likes to sing.
So if I find something
that I do, it's to sing.
Ooh, I know what I would be.
I would be a basketball
player, play at Duke,
then go to Golden State Warriors,
play with Kevin Durant,
Steph Curry, Draymond Green.
By the way, Kevin Durant
left OKC so I'm sorry.
Oh, Thunder.
I'm sorry Thunder for everything.
I know, I loved KD when
he was on the Thunder.
But now is time.
I loved the Thunder, Coach Billy Donovan,
but now it's Coach Steve Kerr.
I would say Famous,
but for all the people who
like famous, I'm sorry.
I gotta let you down,
I like The Way I See It
and I know there's a couple out there
who like The Way I See It.
'Cause that's the only way I see it.
Thanks Buzzfeed.
I had fun and thank you
fans for all your questions.
(yodels)
Goodbye, see you next time on Buzzfeed.
(country music)